trois heures devant un écran à répondre
à des tests psychotechniques de français
mathématiques et anglais
ces tests constituent la première étape
de sélection pour antoine ce jeune
yvelinois de 20 ans en formation de
conducteurs travaux cherchent à intégrer
l'armée de terre en tant que
sous-officier dans le génie travaux
l'une des 100 spécialités proposées par
cette armée on m'avait dit que c'était
assez facile en fait est là bas ce matin
j'ai pas trouvé que c'était évident le
temps imparti
ça je ne savais pas ces tests
psychotechniques permettent deux choses
la première qui permettent finalement
d'évaluer sa capacité à s'adapter au
sein des institutions militaires
donc pour évaluer le potentiel d'un
candidat est également le potentiel
cognitif visant à vérifier sa capacité
ensuite à suivre la formation qui lui
sera dispensée antoine est arrivé hier
après-midi au fort de vincennes après
avoir rempli toutes les formalités
administratives il a passé différents
tests médicaux pour leur direction le
mess pour le déjeuner sous l'oeil
attentif du chef d'edc pour l'europe
pour le repas manger quand même ne
restez pas à jeun pour les épreuves de
sport de cet après midi ici on voudrait
on parle de sélection mais c'est un
entretien d'embauché
donc c'est un entretien le rouge qui
dure trois jours il ya tout un tas de
tout un tas de petits de petit détail
qui rentrent en ligne de compte et nous
on est là effectivement pour remarquer
ces détails le bon comportement va dire
c'est quelqu'un qui est qui s'adapte
après les dernières recommandations des
explications sportive il est temps pour
antoine de s'élancer dans l'épreuve du
luc léger une épreuve physique pour
déterminer la vitesse maximale aérobie
[Applaudissements]
puis direction le parcours de
coordination antoine doit réaliser deux
fois le circuit en moins de deux minutes
14 en franchissant correctement les six
obstacles mais si vous avez effectué par
2 0 une vous avez vous avez d'ailleurs
cette ne disait pas l'avant mission
semble être juste qu'il vous fait perdre
un point ce qu'il donne à 9 19 sur 20
enfin dernière épreuve sportive les
tractions antoine doit maintenant passer
l'épreuve ultime l'entretien de
motivation
ils vont être reçus en entretien en face
à face par an un évaluateur qui va faire
le bilan que justement de ces c'est tous
les tests auxquels ils ont été soumis et
voir quelles sont leurs motivations
leurs projets et voir si leur projet
justement est fiable et 6 et 6 ont fait
pour ce métier
mais la tâche sera facile pour le
candidat qui rêvent d'intégrer l'armée
depuis l'enfance et plus encore depuis
les attentats de 2015
j'avais déjà eu cette idée en tête de
m'engager après mais là c'est vrai que
le fait d attentats qu'on a subi ça
pousse un peu les gens à vouloir être
utile aider leur pays
antoine saura s'il est sélectionné d'ici
une quinzaine de jours
si la réponse est positive le jeune
homme signera son premier contrat comme
204 jeune gibeline eaux en 2015 et
partira dans la foulée faire c'est lui
moi de formation militaire à saint
maixent pour l'armée de terre
quinze mille postes sont à pourvoir en
france en 2016 dont 3000 en ile de
france